- [Mark] Alright, Patrick.
- [Patrick] Nice to be here.
- [Mark] Nice to see you
again. How are things?
What's going on?
- [Patrick] So when I first came here,
that was what, like a month ago?
- [Mark] Probably. Yeah.
- So, when you continue to
have the next crack hit be
the only thing that matters for that long,
it gets, it's insane.
And that's where I'm at.
Shit.
- [Mark] 'Cause our second talk,
you were somewhat clean, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Or were you just broke?
- We were broke.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Broke, and so therefore...
- [Mark] So this has been an extended
bender for you here.
- It turned into one, yeah.
Turned into one.
- [Mark] Not because
of what I've given you.
- No. no. That's like...
- [Mark] Even though I
have given you some money.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And I appreciate that,
but that's like a drop in the...
- [Mark] How have you supported this?
- A tiny bit in an ocean of...
Yeah so, this time, this
has been the worst of all.
I sold my car.
- [Mark] Oh no!
- I sold my car.
That's one of the rules that
you're not supposed to break.
You can always get more crack
or whatever you're
trying to do with a car.
Than the money that you
get for selling the car.
This is the fourth car that
I've sold to a crack dealer.
However, it was 13 years ago
that I did the third one.
It is crazy.
I have had a couple of situations where
things went wrong,
things go wrong a lot
especially when I'm with a
girl that's smoking crack,
it's like, Oh, oh,
here, have all my money.
That's kinda like how it goes sometimes.
And I find myself sitting here,
just desperate.
It's, four in the morning
and all of a sudden,
out of nowhere,
I don't know, I had
money and out of nowhere.
I had no money, no
cigarettes, no drugs, nothing.
And it's like I go crazy.
I come back over here,
I drive back over here and just park
and it's like I have to
get a crack hit somehow.
I have to.
And, I was parked from
like six in the morning
'til nine in the morning in one spot
just sitting in my car and,
down here in Skid Row.
And people were like waking up,
almost more people were coming.
Because the day was starting.
And a couple people came up to the car.
Do you have a cigarette?
And I realized that,
I'm drifting into this.
Where the day starts and you have nothing.
And you gotta go around and figure out
how you're gonna get through that day.
And, what's more important than drugs.
That's most, not food.
- [Mark] So that's the thing
I've discovered recently.
You know, I do a lot of thinking
about this and I interact
with a lot of these people
that are in situations,
similar to yours, maybe
some worse, some better,
but, the priorities are
a huge consideration.
Like I'm a normie, right?
So, for me, love is your first priority.
- Love?
- [Mark] Love. I would say even if it's
money, success, fame.
- You're right. You know
what? That's a good point.
You're right.
- [Mark] So, whatever you think
your main priority is.
It's love, for yourself, your family,
your loved ones, for yourself.
Or your important people in your life.
For me, that's number one.
For an addict.
Your priority is getting the fix.
- Mm-mh.
- [Mark] So, our goals are not aligned.
So we're never gonna see eye to eye
in any kind of relationship.
'Cause you're trying to get that fix.
And you'll do anything to get it
and you'll lie, cheat or
steal, and you'll deceive me
or you'll do whatever you need to.
You'll steal from me or you'll
do whatever to get the fix.
- Mm-mh.
- [Mark] Whereas a normie
whose first priority is love.
And that means probably being honest
and straightforward and
all that kind of stuff.
- Yeah. I do think a little that I have,
I don't know if it was a reputation,
but I think I'm probably
the most honest...
- [Mark] I was gonna say that too.
- Crack head, out here.
- [Mark] You are. You are.
'cause you and I have interacted
several times now off camera.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And I never get the feeling that
you're just trying to scam me
like a lot of these people are. (laughing)
Like pretty much all of them are.
- For example, let me give you an example.
That day, I sat over there,
like how am I gonna do it?
How am I gonna do it?
Check this out.
And I found in my...
- [Mark] Glove box?
- Yeah.
A Starbucks gift card for $25, right.
I'm thinking, maybe I can go to Starbucks
and ask the dealer, that's over there.
If he wants a coffee.
Or maybe I can go to him.
And he could give that as a gift.
When he goes to the next family
birthday party or something,
that's what I'm thinking in my head.
So I go up there
and I see him
and he's right there on the
passenger side of my car.
And, of course he has no desire for the...
The Starbucks it's not worth anything
and he doesn't want it.
And it's like, no, it's like nothing.
I was still not...
He's not gonna give me anything.
It's fine.
I get it.
So watch this.
So he's there.
Also, I'm up for three, four days.
So I'm like, it's hazy.
And that's also the case right now.
As he's walking away
I just saw a glimmer,
something kind of like a shadow fall
from him from his pocket.
And he's walking away that way.
And I waited,
I almost wasn't gonna do it.
And then I went over
and opened the passenger door and looked,
and it was a $20 bill on the ground.
Right. What do you think I did.
- [Mark] (laughing) You bought some crack?
- I yelled, Hey.
I yelled at him.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- I yelled at him. Hey man...
- [Mark] You dropped 20 bucks.
- Hey man! Hey! Hey! Hey!
You dropped this.
- [Mark] Wow! That's impressive.
- He came back and picked it up.
- For a crack addict.
That's really impressive.
- And I was desperate,
but that's what I did.
He didn't really say anything,
but then he did give
me a tiny bit of crack.
Not $20 worth, but he
did that, which was good.
- [Mark] The beginning of your story
shows you how desperate an addict can get.
- Yeah. And he said,
when I offered him the Starbucks card,
I want the car.
I'd never heard that before,
I was like no, the car something.
And so then this one real thing happened.
I got a little hit,
I drove away.
I didn't take the hit yet.
And I remembered that I had
the title to my car in the car.
- [Mark] Mm-mm.
- Which I did that because,
sometimes you can get a
loan from that, you know?
So I was thinking maybe
I could get some money.
Not give the car away,
but you can go get a
title loan or whatever.
And I realized that he wants to car,
here's the title.
I turned around, drove back down there
with the title in my hand.
Next thing you know,
the next morning he took the car.
I said, Hey, we agreed on a price.
I was making sure to get more cash
than he wanted to give me.
He probably just wanted
to give me like all drugs.
And I was like, I need to use
the car until this is over.
I can't be out here with nothing.
And the next morning
took the car
and I have no car, (chuckles)
So, I'm living in my apartment,
which is turning into it's just, yeah.
I mean, it's not that bad,
but it's not as bad as...
- [Mark] So your situation now is worse
than it was on the first time?
- Way worse.
Yeah. I mean, it's like, you'd
stop doing anything responsible
and just smoke crack.
And if you do that for a week,
that's really bad.
You do that for six weeks.
That's probably not six times
where it was probably like
six to six power times worse or whatever.
- [Mark] So what is the solution?
Do you have any ideas?
- I need to go to rehab.
Right now,
I went to a rehab for detox
and then something happened.
Something like just a
tiny little thing happened
with the insurance where it's like
a little bit maybe this
isn't gonna work out.
After like a little while, not instantly,
but after a little while,
when it seemed like there
was a discrepancy that,
shouldn't have been, I
was hearing two stories
I was hearing something
different from my insurance.
Like, Oh, well this guy can leave.
Instead of going from here
to directly to another rehab,
that's the thing, that's
the way you do it.
Sorry, I'm just gonna go.
Yeah. And I got a ride.
And I knew the reason I was doing it was
because I was gonna go
home and come down here.
I have a friend that
has basically been
just feeding me money.
Sort of as a
loan against
my tax return refund that's coming.
So,
I think the last one
of those transactions was last night,
but there was a lot of them.
That's basically the main
way I've been getting money.
- [Mark] So you're spiraling.
- Yeah.
When I take a hit like
I took a hit earlier,
sitting down over there
and,
take a hit.
I blow it out.
And I say, I love smoking crack.
I love it.
Yeah. That's what I love to do.
- [Mark] You're just not ready to quit.
- Yeah. It's like as much
as I can do until it's over.
It's not like,
okay stop and then go to rehab.
It's as much as I can
do, as much as I can do.
This is just the most embarrassing.
I'm already like that on your channel.
Well, we can call it honesty, I guess.
- [Mark] Well, you're
one of the most honest...
- So, the honesty
is revealing some
ridiculous, embarrassing behavior.
Yeah. And right now I don't even care.
Right. Right now.
I'm thinking about,
someone I met right
before I came in here that
like I'm in that state.
- [Mark] One of the
girls I just interviewed?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Is that what you're
talking about? (laughing)
- Yeah.
- [Mark] As she walked out, you...
I'd like to maybe see
what she's doing later.
Last night.
What did I do?
Last night,
you gave me some money
and someone else gave me some money.
And that was over.
I went home and did my thing at home,
which is just, yeah.
Porn, porn in my bedroom,
on my phone, smoking crack.
'Cause actually,
that's like the best way to do it.
Down here.
- [Mark] It's too expensive.
And dangerous.
- The girls on the video,
always do what I want.
(laughing)
- [Mark] These girls
are trying to rob you.
- They do the thing that
I'm wanting them to do.
- [Mark] Your wallet will still be there
after watching porn I guess.
- Mm-mh. It it's free.
Which is funny,
'cause I don't watch porn
at all when am clean.
It's funny.
People are surprised about that.
So, then after that I took a
shower four in the morning.
I had $12.
Right. So, and I'm out of it.
And I took a bunch of pills,
like this muscle relaxer,
Molly's dangerous,
but I took a bunch of them,
which is contributing to my sort of like,
you know what I mean?
Like this is different
than the crack high.
- [Mark] Yeah, you seem
to be more relaxed.
- So I have the $12. I'm home, no car.
I'm going downtown to get $10.
A big hit, $10.
I go downtown, get it, find a place to sit
in a dark place, against the wall.
And do that.
That was my whole thing.
And I walked far at four
in the morning, last night
there was the buses weren't running.
I can use Lyft.
I'm able to do Lyft every whenever.
Now And there was no lift.
I walked really far.
I walk around and looking for people.
Seeing what's up,
but I didn't see a
single person until some,
basically like a transvestite in a,
Is that what you call It?
I don't know like a...
- [Mark] Transgender.
- Transgender, like a biological male,
female in a van, sees me.
It's funny.
It's like the reverse
of what I used to do.
Sees me. And I could
see that he looked at me
and then like turn, and turn around
and came and parked and came next to me.
What are you doing?
We're busy walking downtown.
I get into this, this van,
they just drove me for like yeah,
nothing happened.
But I was like, I don't
know what's gonna happen.
Maybe we can do something, do
some sex thing with my $12.
Finally after that,
she dropped me off down a
little bit further down.
And then a Lyft guy
came and I came out here
and I got the $10 thing from a guy I never
I just go to whoever I
don't know necessarily.
Like I should, I probably should always go
to someone I've been to before,
but then everyone has a down here.
So, he does the whole thing.
He gives me the 10,
like gets it, I see it.
Puts it into the...
breaks it and gives it to me.
It was fine.
It's very good.
I walk away.
I go find a spot like I said.
I sit, put it in there.
It's not crack.
- [Mark] Oh no!
- it's fake. Right?
And so, it's funny how
that is just the worst
thing that could happen in my life.
My life has now changed into that.
Anyone would say like the worst thing
what was the most, the worst
thing that could happen?
Your brother...
your parent die, your kids die, you know.
For me, the worst thing that can happen is
like the last hit is not real.
So I immediately just started walking
all around downtown looking for this guy.
I still haven't found him.
I was really going to fight,
well I've never done.
If he's riding down the street,
my plan was to be like a Linebacker, NFL.
Just sprint at him and tackle him
and do that, see what happens.
- [Mark] So your life is getting
into dangerous territory now.
- I don't care.
That's the thing I do not care.
Right? Like, don't care.
- [Mark] I'm not sure this is the answer,
but are you religious?
Maybe talked about this?
Like I'm not at all, but...
- Last night I had two
different things happen.
- [Mark] 'cause we had
a conversation recently,
in between our interviews where
you and I talked about maybe
a religious conversion
is the answer for that.
- Well, I do believe in Christ.
Right? That's how I am.
I read the Bible.
I've said a lot, there's
no doubt in my mind
that Jesus Christ is who
he say says he is, right?
Like that that's real.
God is real.
So, I don't know if it was
the time that the, it wasn't.
It was earlier in the night.
Earlier in the night when I was down here.
There's a guy that sits on a corner
and hands out food for free.
And wants to read a prayer,
he's a Christian.
So, he asked me.
I was walking by.
I thought he might not ask me.
Because maybe I don't look
like as homeless as everybody else.
But he asked me, I said, okay.
And then he read the thing.
It was the Lord's prayer,
Our father who I remember, you know.
So, which I recently read a book,
like a bunch of times in a row
about that...
I'm into that yo.
So then,
he wants to pray for me.
Are we healing?
He basically has had
me repeating a prayer.
Like, G, I repent.
I do like this prayer,
repeat with him and I start crying.
Right. I start crying.
So then he just continues to
pray for me as I'm crying.
Right. Crying.
And then I had the burrito,
and then I went like
when that was over, I walked,
20 feet down and stood
there and was crying.
Yeah. Yeah.
And that's a,
I didn't even think of it until right now,
but I'm telling you that always,
for me, the presence of
God, involves me crying.
That's happened probably,
dozens, hundreds maybe of times
over the last 20 years.
Right. When it's got in
and you know what that
is it, you who maybe
don't believe in God or what,
it's love, like you
said the first priority,
God is love.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Those are the same thing.
- [Mark] Exactly.
- So, if you say love, I say God,
we're talking about the same thing.
- [Mark] I agree 100%
- Yeah. And so,
On I went.
So that happened last night.
And also last night as I was walking,
after taking those pills
and I'm walking down here.
I was thinking maybe God's not real.
Maybe He's not real.
It could be 'cause.
I wouldn't mind dying.
You know what I mean?
I wouldn't. I say that,
I wonder if I mean it.
Put the shame like,
the shame, that embarrassment, honestly
this is kind of cool,
but this is putting
that several levels up.
We're just going like,
who knows how well this
is gonna turn into.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Well, I mean, back to
what you were just saying
about love and God and all that.
I think the purest form of love
or calling it is self-love.
'Cause if you're able to love yourself
you're gonna love your children
and your loved ones and your family.
Everyone around you.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] In the appropriate way.
- Right.
- [Mark] That's why I tell women that's ,
Oh, I just want to do it for my kids.
Don't do it for your kids,
do it for yourself.
And then your kids are gonna benefit
in the strongest way possible
because you're loving yourself.
- That's absolutely true.
And I have zero love for myself.
I'm a monster.
I'm sick.
- [Mark] No, you couldn't be
doing the things you're doing.
If you loved yourself.
- Oh, I hate myself.
I despise myself.
- [Mark] And common sense is
not gonna get through to you.
Cause you're clearly
worthy of loving yourself
and you're loved by everyone around you.
- I have a lot of people
who love me a lot.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- A lot of people,
- [Mark] I love you.
I think you're amazing.
And not because you're getting
a lot of views on my channel
just because I think you're a great guy
and you deserve a happier, healthier life,
but I don't know how to
get that into your skull.
- Right. There's a guy
that I'm really close to
that is struggling in the same way.
Like the same thing.
Except he holds it together better.
Like he doesn't for broke.
- [Mark] Cause you'll be
homeless in a tent soon.
- Right. He doesn't do that.
Right. He does well.
He owns a home,
and has a good job and all that.
So we talk and, there's a
couple people that I talk to,
but that's it.
But I just absolutely
avoid a lot of people.
Just don't respond to them.
I haven't spoken to my mother.
I should probably text her right now.
In a month,
she was gonna come and help me,
and I was happy about that.
I needed someone to come help me.
I got my apartment.
I was just laying there.
Just anyone there to help me.
Would have been...
And she was gonna come,
but then the night, like
she doesn't come on a day.
The night before that day,
I wound up getting some money somehow.
Came down and just was
smoking, smoking, smoking.
So she was texting me I wasn't responding.
So she did not come.
She's like, hey if your
smoking I'm not gonna come.
Yeah.
No car.
Doing a lot of bus rides
and Lyft rides down here.
- [Mark] Were you were coming
to Skid Row frequently before
you and I first met?
- If I'm using,
if I'm clean I never come to Skid Row.
Pretty much...
- [Mark] Like when you're going
down to Figueroa and picking
up girls and all that.
- It depends.
If I'm just trying to just get some drugs,
like if I have a little bit of money,
I'm just trying to get high,
and that's it.
I would drive straight down here.
- [Mark] Oh, you would?
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
Trade street, the same place.
Right? Where it's there.
- [Mark] Yeah, 'cause I've
never seen you here before.
- Well, yeah.
I wouldn't really, I
would drive and go home.
You wouldn't see me.
I drive, get it and leave.
I wouldn't be here.
If I was going on a...
- [Mark] Can you get
crack on Figueroa street?
- Yeah. So, if I was doing that,
that's more of an extended
thing going down there,
then down there that the people
would start to recognize me.
They'd start to see me around,
could I be down there driving
around and just crazy.
Driving around for...
- [Mark] Is crack the same
thing down there as it is here?
- Mm-mh. So much.
It's easier to get here.
- [Mark] Well, here it's everywhere.
- Everywhere everybody has it here.
- [Mark] You can't walk a block without...
- Down there It's better.
If you know somebody in order to go.
I don't know if I should
say the names of other...
- [Mark] No you shouldn't.
- People that are on this,
that have been interviewed by you.
Other people that have
been interviewed by you.
- [Mark] If you do, I'll take them out.
- A friend. Yeah. I
have a friend down there
that I was actually,
when I first thought of coming
in and talking to you today
I was thinking like, bring her too.
Let's talk together.
I don't know why I was thinking that.
(sighs)
Let's see.
So, it's fake.
And now I'm just walking around,
looking for this guy so
that I can demand a $10 bag.
And along the way I talk
to people ask me like, people were like...
while this one guy was backing me up,
told me I know who that guy is.
He's over there.
And, I basically did
what I've been doing this
whole time is asking people for money.
That's how I've been doing it this time.
Asking people for money,
'cause I don't have any money.
And there was no way there
was, it was just like
not possible that I was
gonna come down here
for that last hit and not get it go home.
There's no way.
So, I asked one of my closest
friends I had given him
I need money.
She did.
And then I thought of you, I'm here?
It's the day.
I know you wanna interview
me and let's do this.
And so I've been down here.
- [Mark] So common sense is not the answer
cause clearly you're sensible
and you're intelligent.
And I can tell you that
if you continue with this
path, you'll end up homeless.
And then living in a tent on Skid Row.
- Part of me thinks that's
why that's what should happen.
- [Mark] See, that's where
I think that the real core
of the issue is it's your self love.
- Right?
And if you believe you deserve that
and that's what my channel's about.
People think my channel is
about addiction or something.
It's not, it's about self-love.
- Okay.
- [Mark] And self-love is why these people
believe that Skid Row is
tolerable or acceptable.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you're starting
to have that same mindset
of believing that this would be okay.
Or this would be what you deserve.
- I don't know if I
think it would be okay,
but it would be appropriate.
- [Mark] Yeah. See that's what I hear
with so many people I've interacted with.
Where, women who are
looking for Prince Charming.
And I've basically played
that role with them
in their lives.
Not romantically necessarily,
but like look, I'm gonna
help you get housing,
and I'll get your life together
so you can do everything you need to do.
- Does it ever work.
- [Mark] Never.
- Never.
Do you know why?
They smoke crack?
That's it.
- [Mark] Or Meth.
- Drugs, Whatever.
That's the only thing.
It's not like I need a house.
- [Mark] So, do you
believe the drug addiction
is the cause of that behavior?
Or do you believe the lack of self-love,
which leads to drug addiction
is the cause of that behavior.
Because they were abused
as children probably.
- Yeah. It's like, what came first?
The chicken or the egg?
- [Mark] They're probably
the same thing in the end.
- We'll, I mean for me
I think the self hatred is pretty...
very very much connected
to the drug addiction.
- [Mark] Yeah. That's what I'm saying
it's basically the same thing.
But in the beginning when it started,
- [Mark] But if you go to a rehab
and you got clean from the
drug, you're not cured.
You'll relapse 90% of
the time, 95% of them.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So that's why I
suspect drug addiction is
not the real issue.
It's the self-love, is the real issue.
- Yeah. If you frame it
that way where self-love
- [Mark] But I can throw
you in jail for three months
and you'll be clean. Right?
But as soon as you get out (laughing)
you're gonna march down here.
- Maybe not.
Actually I probably wouldn't.
- [Mark] But eventually something
would trigger it and you would.
- The pattern would be eventually
I would come down here.
It probably wouldn't be immediately.
If I was in jail for two days,
Yes. Immediately, but three months.
Yeah. And I was starting to get there.
Whenever I go to rehab,
it takes a little while
I sleep and eat sleep and eat.
And for some reason I was
throwing up every night,
like I eat too much food...
So that's a horrible feeling.
You wake up in the middle
of night you're throwing up.
Have to go in there.
- Throwing up every night.
I can't poop for some reason.
I can't, I don't know why,
I realized, I haven't taken
a dump in like two days.
What's going on here? I'm throwing up.
And then I kinda got through that.
And I started to get to just the beginning
of the point where it's like, okay.
Let's get clean.
Let's be clean.
I got the book out of my bag.
I bought a bunch of books
and I'm gonna read it.
Reading that book would be
something you do because you're clean.
It's actually a book about
the sermon on the Mountain,
the great book.
And, I think it was that same day
that the the opportunity
to leave happened.
So now,
I am trying to get into impact.
That's the plan, right.
- [Mark] A rehab.
- Impact is more of a hardcore rehab.
The ones I've been going to are like,
they off, easy.
They're basically just like
a different place to sleep.
They feed you.
- [Mark] And how long is that for?
Well, that one was for five days.
Oh, shoot!
If I would've, it would've
been probably 30 days.
And then outpatient after that.
Impacts' longer.
I don't really know
everything about Impact.
I just know that it's tough.
It's probably like the
type of place that I need
where people are gonna tell me,
They're not going to sugar
coat anything with me.
And yeah.
That's the thing. If I do that,
if I go and get clean,
I'm gonna have to look
at some nastiest shit
that has been occurring.
And that I've been doing. Like nasty.
It's just bad.
- [Mark] Well you have the ability
to be honest with yourself.
And that's a great skill.
- Yeah. But, I'm being
honest with myself about...
should I be doing?
That's hard, I don't have
my full vocabulary to
unfortunately... (laughing)
That's rough.
That's like almost scary.
- [Mark] As I keep saying,
courage is going to be the answer
to all these problems
that we see on my channel.
- Anyway,
So I cleared.
I left that place on Thursday,
Thursday night.
It so happened at that place.
It's Impact is closed
Friday through Monday,
today's Monday.
So someone told me what to do.
I called Friday with the
message and starting Tuesday.
Right. I gotta call.
And then every day I call
until there's a bed available.
That's what you do if you
wanna go to rehab there.
Right.
So, I think I will do that.
I mean, I probably will do that.
- [Mark] I would urge you to do it.
I'm gonna call you five
times and make sure you do.
'Cause otherwise you're
gonna end up, (laughing)
your life's gonna just...
- And the answer then we'll be yeah, yeah.
Yeah man, it's just, I don't
know what to say, Mark.
I don't know what to say.
But I'm actually enjoying myself today.
I'm having a good time today.
For what that's worth.
What other crazy shit...
- [Mark] But it's gonna get worse.
Without a car, you lose
the apartment, you lose...
- Yeah. The apartment.
I mean the rent's not paid February.
Yeah. my dad had eight grand of my money.
Paychecks go to him and I owe him,
I don't even know the number.
I owe him some money.
We have an agreement where
I pay him every month.
I pay like like 365 times 17 payments.
Or however much that is
when even to pay the rent
when I left, I just went and smoked.
So he did the right thing actually.
He said I did not pay the rent.
I took the entire debt.
Like I put whatever.
I took your money for that.
Like you said, I'm gonna
finally do what you tell me.
- [Mark] Where is Impact located.
- Pasadena.
- [Mark] Yeah I'll make
sure you get there tomorrow.
Or whenever they get a bed.
- I live at Highland
Park Impacts at Pasadena.
- [Mark] You call me
I'll give you an Uber ride
or whatever you need. Yeah.
- I got a lot.
Yeah. I got a lot of
people I can do that. Yeah.
- [Mark] I think that
might be a good first step.
- Yeah. I mean, yeah.
So, having kind of established
a pattern of coming down here
and I realized that somehow with Venmo,
I can use Lyft, even though
my balance is nothing.
So I'm lyfting down here, boom!
And I made a rule for myself.
Here's the rule.
Do not take a hit down here, go home.
Go home, because if you
take a hit down here,
I take a hit down here,
I'm in a tent.
It's gone.
It's ridiculous.
And that's the rule.
I even tell it to some of
the guys that I get it from.
That's my rule.
And I think I followed it once.
Yeah.
I just give money away to...
- [Mark] If you end up down here.
- [Patrick] It's a fantasy thing.
It's like there's no self-love.
Nobody loves me.
I hate me and I hit a crack.
It makes it seem like that's not the case.
It makes it seem like...
- [Mark] That all goes away.
- [Patrick] like somebody wants me.
Like, I'm powerful.
I'm chasing these girls.
- [Mark] I think they've done studies.
I think Portugal, they did this where they
they took addicts and they put them
in social situations where they had like
they made friends and there's
maybe love in their lives in some form.
And that was much more effective
in fighting addiction than anything else.
- That is how the 12 step...
I have a lot of people
like that in my life.
You know,
we're all clean.
We support each other,
there for each other.
And I am in that.
I'm part of that when I'm clean,
but then (fingers snapping)
it's a hit I'm out.
I'm out.
- [Mark] All I can tell you is,
so you have this one
negative character flaw.
There's a positive character flaw in you.
That balances that I
don't know what it is.
Maybe you do.
Maybe you don't, but I guarantee you
there's something positive about you.
That's just as powerful as this negative.
- That's true.
I know that's true.
But I feel like that's
not relevant somehow.
- [Mark] Not today.
But it might be...
- Not for a while.
- [Mark] It might be.
- You know I could have, I'm 42 years old.
And that makes me,
that disgusts me.
I'm 42 years old.
And actually, I didn't
even think about it,
but as I was walking earlier
looking for the guy that sold
me the tip that robbed me,
my birthday is coming up.
I'm going to be 43 years old, this month.
And, I haven't done anything.
I mean, I've done a lot of stuff,
but I haven't done anything.
- [Mark] So shame is a
big part of all this.
- You know, the things people do,
like the things that are fun.
One of the Lyft drivers
we were coming down here
was like just talking to me
about like late night after
in Korea town, how crazy
it is, how fun it is.
And like everything's there.
And,
people have fun together through life.
Whether it's like partying or whatever,
or clean or with family or whatever.
I was thinking about because
Korea towns' over there.
they're probably having a lot
of fun and girls fun, like.
And I've never done any
of that ever in my life.
I come over here,
I think I like Korea town's over there
and we're driving this way
where the crack is, that's it?
Yeah. That's it.
- [Mark] You discovered crack at what age?
- I discovered crack,
I think I was like 19 or 20.
It was like a weird sex addiction thing.
I don't have a sex addiction.
I'm sure it's sex addiction
now in a weird way,
but I was intrigued by prostitutes
when I discovered that that was even
a thing that existed,
I don't know why,
that was like the only
good time of my life.
My senior year of high school was awesome.
Like the most fun,
I was friends with everybody.
I did everything.
That was like the one
time of my life where
like, you know, this is great.
Where everything was succeeding and I,
being with girls,
but you go down the
prostitutes for some...
I don't even know why I go down there
In Pomona I'm going down to Pomona.
That's where this all happened.
And they were feeling crack.
I think I talked about
this in the first video.
Yeah. That's how I discovered it.
Didn't even know it existed.
Didn't even know it was a thing.
And, Once I felt that feeling.
Yeah, that was that.
And so, that's been the story,
it's like ,
you know what?
When I'm clean, I've told the story.
The story seemed different.
Like seemed like, Oh yeah, he,
you know, he went to school
he went and he traveled, moved to the....
Yeah. He has a good job.
He's got a good job here.
A good job there.
But really, it's like the
whole story of life is this.
Everything is this.
Yeah. So, yeah.
It's crazy.
Soon as I finish and I
don't have any, it's like
my mind does automatically,
just on my phone.
I'm like where can I get money.
I got to get money somewhere.
I'll find money somewhere.
Yeah. I'll do it.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Take a hit on the street.
See a girl.
Yeah. And think maybe I can get a
blow job from that girl.
Then it's like what?
No, that's not. (laughing)
That's not how that works.
- [Mark] You end up
getting killed eventually.
- It's not her because
she's the nearest one
but a crack hit changes that.
I've been out here, on the sidewalk.
Yeah. It's just like,
what am I doing?
- [Mark] I'm gonna try
to make sure you go to
Impact as soon as possible.
- I got a call tomorrow.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I have people on that.
- [Mark] Excellent. That
sounds like a great plan.
- What else?
- [Mark] Just stay out of
trouble in the meantime.
- Yeah. Well, I'm gonna
try to finish strong.
(laughing)
- Yeah. I will fall asleep.
I could tell that the...
- [Mark] How many days you've been up.
- Not that long.
I woke up on Saturday at 4:00 PM.
That's the only sleep I had,
since leaving that place.
It was like Saturday, all day
from five in the morning until 4:00 PM.
Yeah. So I'm like kind
of in a similar state
to when I was here first time.
- [Mark] Today's Monday. So.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
I'll see what's going on with the...
What's going on out there.
- [Mark] Don't get in a fight out there.
- yeah.
I was actually looking
forward to fighting.
I've never fought.
- [Mark] No, no, no.
- Earlier, when that guy robbed me.
- [Mark] You don't want to
get in a fight down here.
I don't wanna fight down here.
And I was even thinking like,
this is gonna be like a
a day to be remembered
when that white guy,
that crack head white boy
that walks around, went crazy.
I'd be remembered for that.
I was thinking that I
was gonna try to do it.
- [Mark] It really ends
the way you plan it.
It's funny
Walking through super bad neighborhoods,
like I don't care,
I walked by a guy near my apartment
last night, like, Hey, where are you from?
he was like a gang member.
Yeah. I don't care.
- [Mark] No, you're getting into reckless,
behavior.
- [Mark] All right, Patrick.
Well, thank you so much
for coming in again.
And I hope we do many more
of these and I hope you
show some improvement
and I'd love to...
- Thanks for helping me out too.
- [Mark] I'd love to document you
getting your shit together.
However, you figure it out.
- Yeah. Like that's
either going to be that,
which that's happened every time.
So, but this is like a
different, so I don't know
but that's always happened.
I got my shit together.
- Or, It's harder to
manage coming down here
like living down here
or die or death somehow.
Yeah.
- [Mark] So Patrick, here
we are the next morning
after our talk yesterday.
This is Tuesday now.
How did it go yesterday?
What happened last night?
- Well, I had fun during the day,
thinking I was gonna have a super fun,
super fun thing last night
had like plenty of money
and a lot of crack and I
got tackled and mugged.
Yeah. Which has never happened...
- [Mark] At Skid Row at night.
- Yeah. Two guys, I was talking to a girl
like I tend to do,
- [Mark] You had the whole plan.
- I was sitting on the curb.
I had as much money as much crack
as I will ever have on me down here.
And that was exciting,
but I didn't,
Being up for so long,
my brain didn't compute
those two guys standing.
I think everybody's nice.
- And while they were going
to pin me down, I struggled.
I think I did a decent job struggling.
Took the money and the crack.
I went from having like as good...
In my mind, right?
As much fun as I could possibly have to...
- [Mark] being broke.
- No money, no crack.
- [Mark] Oh! I'm sorry.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So, that's a memory that you remember
- [Mark] January and now
February has been a rough
ride for you.
- Mm-mh.
- [Mark] All right.
Well, Patrick, I wish
you the best of luck.
I think rehab is probably
a great first step.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And I'll try to make
sure that happens for you.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Thank you for being so honest.
- Lets see what happens.
- [Mark] You're one of
the most honest people
that I've interviewed. It takes
a lot of courage to do that.
- My boy John,
I'm from New Bedford,
not gonna be happy with me.
(laughing)
- [Mark] I'll leave out the crazy.
I'll leave out the crazy details
- Dude! What you doin'?
Don't do that.
It is what it is.
And this is becoming a thing.
Like chronicling.
- [Mark] Well, I think keeping it hidden
and pretending it's not happening,
is what gives it this power
that undermines you life.
- I don't really keep it hidden.
But I don't like telling you...
(laughing)
I don't tell YouTube.
- [Mark] I think being on a platform
like this is a very powerful way of...
- I guess you're right.
Keeping it hidden from...
- [Mark] 'cause you talked
one-on-one to your therapist,
is that, I dunno
- I tell people, but might
tell my people what's going on
what happens?
Okay. For whatever reason,
I ran into you this time,
which is by far the
worst time ever by far,
and, I have done this.
Why did that happen?
Who knows things happen exactly. Yeah.
- [Mark] Well, I'm
optimistic for your future.
All right.
Well thank you so much.
Until next time.
Don't smoke crack.
(laughing)
- [Mark] Thanks.